hi everyone it's Jerry let's have a look
at a game from the recently concluded
super bet rapid in Blitz this was an
event won by Magnus Carlson
he has the white pieces this was a round
five Blitz game five minutes with a two
second increment against kyriel
shevchenko
let's have a look Sicilian Defense
Dragon Sicilian
and to be a bit more exact we have an
accelerated dragon
now whether you're facing the dragon or
playing the dragon I think this game has
something for you I think I'll be
sharing some tips you may find helpful
for either color
now a basic note or two about this
accelerated dragon
and this guy stays home for just a hair
these two guys have this direct pressure
on D4 white has to tend to that
only now comes Knight to F6 black is
with this accelerated and dragon placing
an Ephesus on kingside deployment and
while this is going on
there's one piece or Pawn staying home
and it's this guy
a reason for this black would like to
with this accelerated Dragon play D5 in
one go if it's available this is often a
liberating move for black
the most popular reply in this position
is Bishop to C4 very active diagonal
that takes into account the D5 Pawn
break
at the same time the bishop on C4 is
accessible to Night Moves later on Rook
moves
what is White's ID in this game not the
most common but certainly a fine move
Knight B3
withdrawing the Knight so that
the queen has direct View
of D5 watches out for that D5 break
okay
in this game D6 is the follow-up and the
reply
is F3 securing the center watching out
for any bothersome Night Moves
now if instead of D6 black castles it's
important playing as white not to just
be in autopilot mode
or in other words not it's important not
to tree
castles
in the same way as D6
if you're playing
F3 here is white black could now play D5
it seems like you don't have enough
support for it
but the tactics are there the Dynamics
are working out for black to get this
move in the very move white has been
trying to prevent
how is this working out after it takes
this guy goes here this is hit now for a
third time how you defending it what are
your options
Bishop C4
could be undermined with this sharp move
B5 one of these two is now
uh one of these two is going to be
distracted from defending D5 and even
right around the corner Bishop F5
looking pretty irritating
my point
if castles don't go with F3
considered best here is Queen D2
what is a difference with these two
moves D1 is now vacant four the queen
Rook
if black tries D5 now chop here we have
a different way to defend D5 we don't
have to go with this
Rook a to D1 computers more a fan of
Rook a to D1 rather than Queen side
castles to defend doesn't want to go
into an opposite side's Castle's
position now that white is up the
material
if you go into an opposite sides
Castle's position maybe material is not
that important a factor
okay
difference here
castles D6 don't treat them the same
D6 F3 castles Queen D2 play develops
normally from here Bishop E6 Queen side
castles Knight Improvement King
Improvement Rook Improvement
here come the h-bonds
H4 met with H5
there's a hook this guy right here
how can we get at it G4 can't do it
right now F3 would hang
so Bishop E2
now if you're playing as black if you're
looking at this move Knight to C4 I'd
like to
mention
think more about that Knight C4 move
only after this guy
has taken a step that way you know when
you're in there white has to spend a
second move to remove the Knight
okay
the Black Knight doesn't hop in there in
this game but just no
I think a little tip there regarding
Tempe in the position
play follows with A6
and now we have Bishop to D4 so
this may be attempting move playing as
white right here Bishop to H6
even one move earlier it may have been
tempting before Bishop E2
uh this is not really a good idea for
white to try and eliminate the dark
Square Bishop in this case
because we would have
this thematic sacrifice black would have
this thematic sacrifice to blast open
the king side in this
uh is going to distract white from
trying to pursue an attack against the
black king these Knights are very strong
Defenders for the king side and black is
now going to be reminding white very
soon about the weaknesses on the king's
side
so we have to be mindful in other words
why it has to be mindful of this
thematic exchange sacrifice on C3
white is addressing that right now with
Bishop to D4
so when I'm reviewing for these games
here when I'm preparing for this video
this video one of the
things that stuck out to me is when I
see Bishop to E2 I think to myself
isn't the consistent follow-up to play
G4 isn't that the idea we went to E2 to
watch over this so we could play G4 why
is G4 not played now
there's an issue with G4 right now let's
see what that is
black would be able to take
and after the move F4
the Knight can hop in here
Chop Chop H5
yet again we have this idea by black to
go with the exchange sacrifice on C3
if you take with the pawn you're gonna
get squashed Knight takes E4 hits the
Queen the knight's gonna be hopping in
there probably very soon
if you take with the queen this is a
very messy position
black has been successful at least with
the distracting white from going all in
attacking the king
white has some things to watch out for
there's a discovered attack looming
some night move
my point
white has to still keep care keep a
watchful eye over this exchange
sacrifice
don't be in a rush to play G4 just yet
white does follow up in the best way
Bishop D4 is considered best
now I know this is only a five minute
game two second increment but
we got a great player here obviously
uh extremely accurate play by Carlson
even though it's only A5 too
alright Bishop D4
first this move carries with it
a
there's a there's a technical
threat here
the reply is Queen C7
now Black's last move was A6 and it
would seem you're playing A6 to follow
up next with B5
but if B5 is played
white could bring this into a technical
position
white could knock this Knight out and
not be afraid of this guy the diagonal
is shut and more
most importantly the Queens come off
so there isn't this concern there
wouldn't be this concern of uh
some attack against either side's King
is turned much more Technical and now
white would have this healthy
three to two majority on the queen side
it likes this position very much for
team white following up with A4 from
here this is a dead piece
and this is the big positive now for
white
my point Bishop D1 we're watching over
exchange sacrifices we're looking maybe
to tame this bishop and we're also a
moment away from bringing it into a
technical phase an end game phase
all right black ducks that
gets out of this idea to
go into an ending
if white is taking in this position it's
not the same Queens are still on King's
safety is still a big issue
B5 B4 A5 A4 where are these guys going
not a good idea for white to take the
knight in this position
okay
now that the queen is on C7 by the way
there's a little less worry for white
about this exchange sacrifice The Rook
is not in direct contact with the Knight
anymore
okay only after Queen C7 do we have now
G4
H takes G
F4
now this grabbed my attention as well I
thought a knee-jerk reaction to
you know I I was just in autopilot mode
myself right here I was thinking you
just capture right back
this would give these pieces all three
of these pieces can get to G4
of of these captures the Knight captures
are considered uh best here there's a
really cool defensive line here for
black I want to highlight this I found
this really instructive
if white is going with this capture here
F4 first of all move played in the game
consider the very best move but right
next to it second best is this capture
now if that captures on board
black could take with either Knight
let's say this Knight is capturing
and then white is following up with H5 I
have a pop quiz for you
how would you react here as black
if you'd like to go ahead pause the
video see what you would come up with
okay
important defensive test for you playing
on the black side there is only one move
that keeps black in the game
and that is Bishop H6
not only attacking the queen
but now blockading this Pawn
black can now follow up with this move
G5 and this guy is kind of now working
against White
so I would prefer not to have this Pawn
on the board Black's using it as a
shield for his own King and has managed
to close the king side and buy himself
time to
Advance on the queen side maybe with the
the B Pawn the a pawn
so it's a nice defensive resource that
black would have this sequence right
here is just a two move sequence
flicking in Bishop H6 and then getting
in G5 changes the character of the
position entirely
okay
the move in this game is f for pressing
pressing against the Knight
where does it go
this is where black goes wrong very very
easy to go wrong in this position the
move played in the game is Knight C
Knight to C6 and it's over
we're gonna get
one forceful move after another and the
black king side is gonna get ripped
right open
what are Black's options here
the best move
is surprisingly enough a peace sacrifice
B5 this is considered best
let's see what this looks like
it says takes takes
here push the Knight around
we get into this really
messy position where black manages to
exchange
at least a pair of Rooks and how in the
world are you supposed to assess this
one
computer no problem for the computer it
says it's around even
okay I almost feel like I would prefer
to be maybe more than almost I think I
prefer to be black here
especially if you get the Queens off
that's a group of Five Pawns they're all
passed
okay
that's a pretty wild line to be sure to
go for a peace act to Simply ignore this
pressure on the Knight and just launch
the v-pawn
okay he doesn't launch the B Pawn he
goes with the more human move it's only
a Blitz game he goes with Knight to C6
what's the other human-like move I would
say it's to dive into this Square how
could that be destroyed you take the
Knight and then push on with the H Pawn
if Pawn takes Pawn you swipe the Knight
take here is one of many winning
continuations and if you're taking with
the Knight that's getting busted up
take the Knight
F5
Queen G5 right around the corner
crushing attack
okay this goes nowhere Knight C6 the
move played in the game that also goes
nowhere let's see how this one finishes
up very direct play Bishop takes Knight
Bishop takes Bishop Knight D5
everything's hitting with an attack
Queen's hit Knight is removed recapture
another threat Knight D4 Bishop takes G4
another threat
Knight takes Knight white takes towards
the center
very simplified no nights on board
who's quicker
one move out from creating tension this
guy is also Under Fire black says go
ahead take it
he presses with A5 trying to open up a
line
trying to get this tension in there
white says I don't want your Rook I want
your king
White's there first
engaging with the G6 Pawn
black continues pushing
Pawn takes pawn pawn takes Pawn
recapture there was a thread here
what do you do here
in the game it's Rook to A8 what other
options are there for black
if you take the pawn
I'll just show one sample line of how
this could get
busted up Bishop to E6 check could
follow
King G7 and Rook D to G1 you see the
threat
let's say this Rook gets out of the
Harm's Way now
whenever you're attacking with these
three majors
don't be afraid to sacrifice one of them
to eliminate a key Pawn
Yep this is leading to me
very simple way
along the files
so there's just no defense at this point
white was simply there first
in the game Rook A8 one final move to
this one
simple enough form a battery on the H
file with Queen H2
and black resigns how you stopping
Queen H7 mate
there's no good answer to that
computers suggesting throw a rook
just to give check it's not some three
check variant though all right so what
what other try might there be if you
move the Rook so that the King has a
square well this is vulnerable
and you would just run into a mate and
two
there's no defense black knows it throws
in the towel so
a very high level game despite it only
being a five plus two
with this one
Feel Free as usual to leave any feedback
to this video in the comments section
below I hope you enjoyed it it maybe
took a thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye